j'ai toujours dit non la reine est une
monstruosité monstruosité je l'ai dit
répéter pendant 8 ans la reine est un
poison toujours qualifié la reine de
dispositif à bout de souffle
[Musique]
le prix est de 42 euros pour un
mégawattheure il est inchangé depuis
l'instauration de la reine le 1er
janvier 2011 et j'observe que ce prix
s'appliquera encore sur l'exercice 203
ce prix est manifestement sous-évalué
par rapport au prix de revient de notre
production nucléaire cette
sous-évaluation engendre un
affaiblissement systématique d'EDF quand
l'idée a été évoqué je hurlais
c'est absurde la justification c'est de
dire que DF a de fait un monopole en
ayant le coup du nucléaire et que
personne ne peut en bénéficier et donc
personne ne pourra jamais investir dans
ce domaine donc la seule manière pour
que les autres puissent investir c'est
qu'ils aient une partie de la rente
nucléaire voilà la justification
regardez aucun de ceux qui ont bénéficié
de la honte d'investi ni dans le
nucléaire ni dans même dans la
production donc on a fait le la fortune
de trader pas d'industriels et vous
voyez des campagnes de communication de
de ces traders qui prétendent vendre de
l'énergie verte
je vends de l'énergie verte
des camarades c'est la mienne
vue d'EDF de considérer que c'est une
contrainte et que c'est empêche de
maximiser le chiffre d'affaires et les
revenus c'est une façon de regarder la
reine il y a une autre façon de regarder
la reine c'est un outil majeur de
soutien à la compétitivité de nos
industries c'est un outil majeur pour
éviter d'exposer les consommateurs
français à des fluctuations du prix de
l'électricité une fois qu'on a dit ça
il y a clairement des choses qui ne qui
ne sont pas satisfaisantes dans le
mécanisme actuel par exemple quand
j'étais ministre de l'énergie à un
moment donné les prix de marché étaient
passés sous les prix de la reine pendant
le covid et ça a été certainement
préjudiciable pour EDF donc je suis pas
en train de dire que c'est un mécanisme
parfait
[Musique]